you have to make a good first impression
when you're connecting with referral
partners or they're not going to send
you any business and you're going to
lose out on one of the best ways you
have to grow your company hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
Mason a question from one of my YouTube
breeders love you guys Brendan who said
I've started a new digital marketing
consultancy agency helping professionals
service-based businesses attract
qualified clients increase revenue and
create automated marketing systems I
want to partner up with companies that
has my type of audience that I like the
track can you give suggestions as to how
should approach these businesses your
passion is contagious and thanks for
what you do cheers brendan so thanks
brandon congrats inserting this new
business exciting time and you're
definitely on the right path and trying
to go out and attract referral partners
instead of just trying to do everything
yourself these guys already have your
audience you just have to convince them
that you are right fit for what they are
doing now when you're approaching
referral partners the best thing you can
do is start off by building some kind of
personal relationship so if you can do
that by a Twitter finding someone who
you know at the company or sending a
specific email to somebody at the
business you get a much better response
rate than just writing into the general
email address okay that's step number
one next you have to clearly define what
you do and add a little more punch to it
yours isn't bad it's not bad it's better
than most people who write into me it's
I've started a digital marketing
consultancy agency okay so we know what
you do we know who you help helping
professional service based businesses
and then the benefits attract qualified
clients increased revenue and create
automated marketing systems online that
last part is a little different it
tweaks my interest a little bit the
creating automated marketing systems is
something that most people won't talk
about so you've done something a little
bit here ready to track my tension but
you need one more pal sentence you got
to end this off with something that's
going to hit them right between the eyes
I make them want to meet with you you
need something that's going to help you
stand out from everybody else some kind
of guarantee some kind of truth some
kind of result that you can provide the
you have some data to back up that is
different because these guys are meeting
tons of people like you you have to find
that way to stand out so it's not bad
that first sentence but you got to add
one more in there that is memorable
people are gonna make sure that they pay
attention to and say I gotta meet this
guy okay those are your first steps now
when you're writing the people you have
to make it seem and you have to have the
intention of it being a two-way
conversation I get people write to me
all the time and they say Evan we've got
this great product I think you're
entrepreneurs we really benefit from it
please help promote us I'm not in the
business of promoting you right there's
tons of guys I could promote I have
enough work on my plate besides thinking
about promoting you but if you come to
me and you think of an opportunity that
we might be able to help each other out
there's something in it for me too
besides just promoting new then it's for
interesting so when you're connecting
with them say you want to learn about
them you know you work with these types
of clients who also need potential help
in you know whatever it is that they do
legal services accounting services
design services whatever it is your
clients need their help as well and you
want to learn about them to build your
knowledge base of who you can actually
refer people on to and when these people
see that there's something in it for
them they're much more likely to take
that meeting okay final step make it
easy for them go to their office go to
their coffee shop go to them instead of
having them come to you I'd always try
to make it in person instead of doing a
phone call or just keep it on email
because you lose a touch if it's only
email you're not going to get any
referrals you've got a you've got a
press the flesh you've got to meet with
these guys but make it easy for them and
final if you want kind of the bonus tip
bring something that they really like I
remember when I first had a meeting with
a PR company that could potentially
refer new brands to my business and has
and it's been a lot of business to this
one company my first contact with them I
had my assistant research the person's
Twitter account and see what she was
posting and she posted that she really
liked going to this little cafe called
little nicky's and the treats that they
had so my assistant told me that and on
my way down to meet them
I would stop by little nicky's and
bought out all their treats and brought
it to the meeting and I didn't say hey I
researched you know I stalked you on
twitter and I found this out about you
that might be a little scary but it's a
it's plausible that you know I was in
the area and i found this coffee shop
and I when I wanted to bring some treats
and her eyes lit up as soon as she saw
the little nicky's treats and so maybe
it's sucking up a little bit maybe its
stock in her a little bit you know you
don't want to say where the information
came from but that set us off on the
right foot and we've done a lot of
business together so if there is
anything personal you can find out
through somebody's twitter stream
they're not gonna be a little bonus to
help you get to know them a little bit
better and be able to make a better
impression when you first connecting
with people you're definitely on the
right path good luck with this business
reaching out to potential partners is
again one of the best and fastest ways
to grow your business because they
already have your target audience if
they like what you do they can refer a
huge stream of ongoing business to you
without you having to worry about going
out and getting new clients all the time
so good luck i love to hear how you're
going and if you want to work on that
last sentence to make a little punch
here and really hit somebody between the
face and and really you know have that
impact to say i gotta meet with this guy
if you work on that sentence and you
send it in to me i'll give you some
feedback on the tube so thanks everybody
for watching if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up below makes
want to do more for you and if you have
a comment about this video or question
for your own company please leave in the
comments section below i always read
those and makes my morning every day so
thank you and i'll see you on the next
episode